[Music]
and welcome everyone and you're just
watching clause ins insane in the end
game let's even get started so the first
game I'm going to show is between magnus
carlsen against alexei sheriff and
that's particularly important when
you're just joining the rank of the
elite the elite chess players that is as
Magnus didn't have trainings with
Kasparov yet so this is pre 2010
Kasparov calls and collaboration so
you're going to see how good cousin
already was at that time so let's get
into this game between Caza and cheer up
so you're gonna join from this position
I chose this position for one particular
reason no it's not yet the endgame
however Magnus realizing that possibly
after plaque would get this Bishop to eh
I'm gonna get that arrow somehow
straight then black will get some
counter chances
why because once this Bishop gets there
let's say here here black eventually
will have a break and these bishops can
come alive and provide some sort of play
so Carlson uses a great psychology in
this game because he says okay I'm
facing alexei shear of mister fire on
the board and in this specific case it
does make sense just to dry up the
position so it takes on these 767 night
takes d7 g3 Knight up six
and here calls and plays very very nice
move following the same Wayne so I do
wonder if you guys can guess what
Magnus played in this position it can't
be too hard as we talk about calls ins
insane endgame
so imagine that your Carlsen and you're
about to take down one of the most
exciting players of the 90s in c5 indeed
that floor would make sense as mentioned
in chat but this is the position he's
not looking forward to calls and wants a
risk-free position where he can love his
legendary opponent to sleep queen c5
queen takes e5 and Knight takes f6 check
and these are these little twists that
grandmasters see and you know newcomers
miss they don't necessarily expect like
these in between moves that little
elegant touch makes it such a good move
GF rook takes e5 so let's just stop here
just for a split second which side would
you take obviously everyone wants to be
on the side of Carlsen however let's try
to be objective forest let's second
which side would you take or is there no
side to take because the position was
balanced
I'll give you one of my takes and one of
my takes is this Bishop it's just a
little bit better than blacks likes
Bishop it's actually just firing into
the wall as this pawn structure is
fairly solid and it's very hard to crack
through so I see white is better healthy
pawns more active rooks black has a
doubled pawn good observation and that
actually also points out that there's
this h6 spawn that can become a
potential target it's not that easy to
come near that near it though on the
other hand there's one important factor
in this position which overrides
everything and that is the fact that
there's an opposite colored bishop on
the board also as mentioned by Chet it's
true White's King is just way better
than blacks because there's no way this
bishop will ever be a bother and this
Bishop being a bother then is still
conceivable that is by all means very
conceivable it's the reason there's a
high probability of a draw in this
position is the fact that there's
opposite colored bishops on the board
and if you're kind of wondering about
the objective truth here it must be very
close to a draw however you shall see
that that does not bother Carlsen okay
eight
kingi to another small little move just
getting away from the dark squares and
coming a bit closer to the center Bishop
d6 c2
so because of this doubled pawns Shirov
decided to play a five and that's a good
move putting this these phones on white
squares however it does limit the scope
of this Bishop and it does stop any sort
of expansion that efore f4 and 85 five
Bishop c4 a4 so it's just making sure
that all of these pawns are fixed on
black and dark squares and maybe he
could potentially attack them but
already in this position we should take
a look and try to find a potential
target in blacks position look and think
about new spawns where could you find
some loose pawns in blacks position that
potentially we could attack in the
future
a for b7 c6h6 so it's very hard to get
to this age six spawn at least it'll
take lots of lots of time to get close
to this guy
however this upon whoever said the apon
is actually the culprit still very hard
to get to the B and C pond however and
the targets will be on the queenside so
if we note that these pawns will be the
potential targets where does this bishop
on c4 belong to in just a side note
sometimes using this thinking
identifying the target and then devising
the plan actually help you to play the
best possible move in the position so is
that Bishop to d1 okay so we want to get
this Bishop to c2 to target the pawn
okay makes sense but what if we want to
attack the b7 c6 bonds
now for that we need to go to e2 and
have three yes and that's exactly what
Magnus played we should be too
now when you guys said Bishop c2 or
bishop d1 he actually has that in mind
so when he plays Bishop e2 says I don't
know Cheryl what is your plan exactly
however I can go Bishop the one at the
time is right once I move this rook rook
c4 had this pawn and Bishop d1 attack
there let's say us should be seven plate
let's see if this happens here I'm just
going to mark a bit of time and now
Bishop d1 and white actually means
opponent gets some winning chances but
the greatness of Bishop e2 is the fact
that it's flexible not only does it
threaten to get the bishop on the long
diagonal it also threatens to go to d1
and threaten the a 1 a 4 point that is
Bishop f3 and put pressure there should
be seven Bishop f3 now another
psychological little detail that I have
to mention so she loves to calculate but
calculation in chess takes time so he
often got himself into big-time troubles
as happened in this game as well so the
reason calls them plays Bishop f3 and
not Luke c1 King g7 and rook c4 because
then it would be abundantly clear that
he is going for the a4 pawn so black
would just double up on the a file
double up on the a file and just hold
still
so what Magnus does is he plays an
enigmatic move and says hey I'm not
going to tell you if I actually have a
real plan here your move sir decide what
you want we should have three we're okay
five rook c4
and these moves are actually kind of
frustrating because mine itself
Brooksie for doesn't accomplish much
because it only puts pressure alone on
the a4 pawn this Bishop is staring into
nothingness at least for the moment ship
f6 and now he plays rook c1 kind of
hinting at Bishop d1 and here black
makes a terrible mistake which is not
not bad like it's not a losing move
however I think it was a bit too risky
and in this specific position because of
the opposite colors blank should have
just stood still with King g7 and if
Bishop d1 just rook e8 and wait for
white to actually come up with something
however she replayed e5 and without
actually going into deep variations do
you guys have any ideas why this move
could be a problem long terms so
baccarat actually you're not wrong I do
think so that sheriff might be even
trying to win still
so what is the downside of this palm
bush
well it doesn't really block the bishop
in fact it's trying to open it up and
just put some pressure on b2 so this e
5:1 actually attacks this guy so after
some exchanges the bishop gets stronger
however after this exchanges let's just
compare these two structures this
structure to this one this was a common
this was still a structure that was
fairly solid all of those funds were
defending each other after this exchange
these have spawns are sort of isolated
both the F on the H font and the a pond
can become a potential target in the
future so even though this is an
aggressive setup and might give some
faint hope over win for Shirov it does
creates more problems that those pluses
that he just got so now plaque is
attacking or pawn so how can we be both
aggressive and defensive the same time
can you guess what calls and plate in
this specific position
indeed Ruby for is a very strong move by
Carlson not only defending the beet soup
on about targeting the b7 point and if
you ever move the beep on my bishop is
just ready to snipe down the c6 spawn
another little bit of a tidbit
if this rook ever gets to b7 there's a
plan of rerouting this Bishop to c4 and
there will be more problems in the
upcoming future for black it would lead
to a long defensive struggle so rook d7
if you go with the other rook as
mentioned by chat rook c5 can't show up
if Bishop d6 there's route d4 and
suddenly black will get an extremely
passive position that a terrible rook
compared to these very active pieces you
can't really take mine because your d8
rook is hanging before rugby - you win
one pawn but you lose - b7 1 and I will
get my eyes on that c4 through that c4
square to the f7 pawn so that's why
Brooke d2 was avoided rook d7 Roxy -
just over defending little move but
making sure that Sheriff has no clear
counter play King g7 and here calls and
does what every Grandmaster would do
bring the King in because that is the
strongest piece on the board can get one
ship f6 just waiting around
however calls in realized it is time for
some action
how can we put some pressure on blacks
position
yes yes yes yes rook c4 just attack the
pawn sometimes chess is simple can't
really play B 5 because the c6 is
falling and not really the problem is
not that there's rook takes a for the
problem is the following takes Tex takes
Bishop takes b2 and rook a7 is the
problem why because not only I put
pressure on b7 but I even set up some
Bishop takes c6 tactics so if you would
go let's say just back to Bishop e5
trying to kick out this rook why does
have bishop takes c6 and if rook d1
kingi to hitting this rook and still
threatening to take on b7 so there's
lots of pressure going on after root k7
and once this pawn is marched up to a 6
there'll be problems might will get an
extra pawn and many many good winning
chances
Brooksie for rook e8 but again Magnus
says hey I can take on eighth a for any
time I like
so I'm just going to go rook at 4 and
probe you a little bit just ask you an
extra question before I actually get
into the details ok 5 yes he can always
take on a for springing in the King rook
c5 trying to exchange Brooke c4 takes
takes Bishop b2 rock a4 and
I think here Shirov showed the signs
that he is homeless going all out to
play to c5 which is very dangerous
because move before black still have
kind of a solid structure
after c5 not only does cousin get a
target on a 7 he will also get some
white squares because no longer does
black have b5 counter moves in the
position c5 now Luke a7 has not played
just yet because there's c4 and the C
pawn can be very fast also side note
takes takes this end game is still drawn
because just one pawn advantage in an
opposite colored position is usually a
draw so cousin plays King f1 and I think
this is the moment where where Shirov
makes a big mistake
can you guess the right move in this
position for shear of not the wrong one
of course
so always think about concepts when
black decided to play c5 that was
actually a sign that he's about ready to
play active chess so he definitely as
some of you mentioned should have played
b5 and hope to activate the C pawn and
probably this would have provided enough
chances to hold the game however b6 was
played but that's just by no but by no
means part of that idea it just doesn't
really work why would you play c5 with
the idea of going down the board and
then just play b6 that is a sign of
hesitation by shear of b6 but this gives
us the option for a typical typical plan
that we were dreaming of earlier on
already so let's get ready for a Magnus
maneuver his idea of it'd be six exactly
my question as well what is the point of
b6 probably trying to remove these pawns
from danger however it lets go of these
white squares
well the bishop isn't doing too much on
b5 however it would do a great deal on
c4 that's why
Magnus played Bishop e2 the bishop is
going this direction and as I said
before if somehow the rook could get on
the seventh rank and put pressure on the
f7 pawn then there would be VL winning
chances also note that this bishop has
zero target the upon is the only target
left but if this is exchanged for the b6
pawn it is clear that it's only white
who can't hope to win the game Bishop c3
this should be five was played rogue d1
King G - Bishop a5 so you can see that
Shirov knows that he can't let Magnus
get behind it okay for king g6 and the
next move is very important and typical
to an apposite colored Bishop game let's
try to be safe here
a4 indeed you want to make sure that
pawn is defended and because Carlson has
a firm control over that c4 square
there's no way that Shirov can create a
passer and if he cannot really create
that passer and there's no way that she
often do anything Bishop c3 and even
though white already has a kind of a
pleasant position he still does have
this idea of g4 which is important for
one reason black had weaknesses but it
kind of was holding together the bishop
can't really go to d3 yet because this
rook is taking control of these crucial
squares and the rook can't really get
behind this F pawn so there's not enough
room to break through however after this
move of g4 magnus opens up the position
and creates a target on f7 F takes G 4
here's the big move my calls on Bishop
e8 not even interested by the jeep on
because that's not as important as the
f1 if you managed to get the F pawn then
you will create a pass one of that II 1
Misha pe8 and there's no way you can
defend it rook d7 is controlled by the
bishop
so the a spawn is falling and suddenly
there are more and more problems to
solve for sheriff yes the position is
probably still balanced but sheriff has
to walk the tightrope should be five
ship f7 King g5 f king g7 attacking then
I could just go over oak at five and
eventually not only your King will be in
danger
but I will have this e pond running down
the board so it is quite clear that she
um is in somewhat of a trouble it's a
place King g5 however King g5 has one
big downside can anybody tell me that is
the big downside of this move of King g5
what if Bishop f6 instead so if you go
Bishop f6 here I can take on g4 and if
Bishop g5 you run into age for ideas and
if you move the King I can check again
and the F on will be very loose that's
why he decided to go King g5 instead
well
sheera was a fantastic and imaginative
player however this is not his type of
opposite color Bishop ending because
this time he has to defend so the main
issue in this position is for sheriff is
his King his King is not too safe and
because of the opposite colored ending
there's no defense on light squares so
bringing this King up to g5 was actually
a dangerous move maybe even inaccuracy
because there's just so many white
squares around this King it's possible
that cousin is going to be able to use
that to his advantage plays rookie 4
puts pressure on the bishop and the pomp
can get 5 rook c4 and these are again
those little tweaks that some of us miss
rookie 4 wasn't really trying to attack
that bishop the point was to lure this
King to that 5 because any time the
bishop will attack this g4 pawn and
either will threaten a check or threaten
a check from behind meaning some extra
time rook d7 Bishop h5 and there to be
an issue
now Shirov is forced to move all his
pieces back just to defend
Jeep on mind you if you lose this Jeep
on I have to connect as passed pawns but
usual even the game also stopping age
five correct rubgy seven and now Carlson
plays a move that is very much Alekhine
style let's try to find a move that's
much in the spirit of Alec I'm or all
your him whichever way you prefer to say
his name
a-five exactly why is this alley oven or
Alekhine style because Alekhine's
favorite idea was to play on both sides
of the board kind of out stretching the
opponent and just putting too much or a
lot of pressure on his opponent's pieces
now it's getting a lot to handle for
sheriff not only does he have to defend
the e4 pawn he also has to deal with
some threats on the side ba rook takes
e5 ok7
Brooke c4 again you can't really start
running with the pawn because you just
lose the g4 pawn and one of the beauty
of the opposite colored endings you can
just drop back to a two even though you
thought that a pawn is just going to be
fast no it's not it's not fast enough
and these two connected fonts are likely
to just win the game it is scary the a
pawn is super scary however it's just
not fast enough so shiro is forced to
move to g7 back rook c5 bouquet seven
rooks e4 room g7 game proclaimed the
draw and this was a brilliant
performance by Carlsen not really in
fact he was just playing that sheer of
who was probably already in time trouble
and played rook c6 mind you if he would
have played rook c5 black could claim a
draw because that would be a three time
repetition Luke c64 okay seven bishop g6
King g5 check no it's not a jaw I'm just
joking
King g5 but again
the problem is it seems like this a pawn
is going to promote however the king the
King the big issue so let's try to find
the key move in this position for Magnus
Carlsen
h4n think again still capture that pawn
so don't look for magic create magic
so we already know that this king is a
little bit dicey over there
you need to do a little bit fresher on
that King and Dan will be close
he'll be close so he played Bishop see
two point being who wants to corner this
King and then the King is cornered
there's just so many mating concepts
that you can use there a for rogue g6
check King aged five and again here
comes that little twist that makes
Magnus such a great player Ruki six he
gives a check first he might have wanted
to play rookie six immediately however
he makes sure that this king is
misplaced and Dan he attacks that Bishop
you know he's setting up bishop g6 ideas
Bishop g7 plate but here probably Bishop
b8 would have been the only move but
again you know let's be fair bit sheer
of this does not look natural
not at all pretty and even though this
could maybe hold the draw it's still
kind of an unpleasant position to play
as black
however Bishop g7 was already a decisive
mistake and it is White's to move and
win
how do they find these moves and
pressure so they notice that the king
wouldn't be as ideal on h5 I'll go back
a little bit so they notice that hey I
want to get rid of this bishop
however I'd prefer this King to be on h5
where I could check it and that's how
they find it they use logic and
calculation of course
so the big move is king g3 and if black
plays King g5 that wouldn't really end
well because of what dear viewers
if you check the king can still go back
there's something more radical in this
position namely white is going to
checkmate g6 just King age five age
forchick GH f4 and Bishop g6 mate now
for some of you just letting you know
that's not the only way to mate bishop
d1 even though a little bit odd-looking
and still kind of a nice little
checkmate from d1 so here instead he
played in rock a5 however he still met
his demise so just that's fine our
little checkmate here it's actually
pretty cute
you're happy with meeting your opponent
upon Wow okay Bishop g6 king gage King
g5 and here share have actually resigned
because there's abundance of pawn mates
in the position so I would say this is
the more stylish one G H and F for
checkmate and it's funny but even in
hangings you can't
checkmate your opponent because the
bishop is covering those squares that
Square is covered by the rook and the
king is controlling all the other
important squares so this was actually a
very nice little demonstration by
Carlsen that mid slow and steady
pressure can actually break super
grandmasters so they really think that
this was pretty cool to see how he
actually does it
but inching ever closer to victory
putting pressure on the position in each
and every case so I do want to show one
more game from bill where he faced none
other than Alexander on issue you're
going to start off from this position
now this is still in the middle game but
one of the things that super
grandmasters and sometimes even
grandmasters do is that they envisage
the ending that they're hoping for so he
knew that this is a possibility and said
hey and anything will be perfect so you
hear he played the five just trying to
close this bishop in so White's play is
going to revolve around aggressive
knights play and playing against those
fairly passive bishops after d5 note
that this bit
ship doesn't really have a scope C takes
d5 Queen takes d5 96 and here comes the
invitation for the end game was an
invitation that it's kind of tough to
refuse so the problem for black is the
following not only does this Bishop have
no targets because there's a big fat
pawn on e5 just blocking the view but
the fact that this Bishop on CA just
doesn't really have a life purpose it
kind of has like a middle game crisis
going on that Bishop so what really
needs to do something about it
I mean take c5 Knight takes e5 and here
on issue actually comes up with a good
solution for that middle game crisis and
he goes Bishop g4 it's a very clever
move by ownership he's saying hey take
my pawn I don't mind but in exchange
I'll get to activate both of my bishops
I put pressure on this night and that
Bishop so hooray this will be great and
if you go Knight d4 I have bishop takes
d4 you have no choice but to take on g4
if you take on d4 this Bishop e2 and you
lose a piece so white is forced to take
Bishop takes b2 and because of the
opposite colored nature of this position
compared to the other one this is more
likely to end in a drop so seeing this
obviously Magnus says no no thank you
I'm not gonna eat that pawn on b7 that's
not to my taste so if you can compare
the quality of this g7 bishop or that g4
Bishop which one would be rather like to
capture as white
the white squared bishop of course
because this bishop at the moment is
still rather useless it can't even
capture their because that pawn is
blocking the view
however this bishop is kind of annoying
and noticing that that bishop is just
being kind of a nuisance for white how
can we get rid of it yeah just play h3
ask where it's going and if alex
ownership would take on f3
there would be Bishop takes f3 and that
pawn would fall now you might be asking
what about efore but if you play e4 i
take here here Bishop g7 note that I
already want one pawn and after Bishop
takes b7 it'll be 2 so why it will be up
upon and in an extra pawn definitely
what is the one to be favored so yet
again ownership goes for rook c8
counter-attacking if H takes g4 rook
takes c5 and because there is no entry
to the d7 square black is doing fine
however the situation has changed
drastically and now cousin does take on
b7 what changed well the fact is in this
case the bishop on g4 is under attack
so that'll be the difference there's no
more e4 because just h g EF bishop f3
and mite is just up upon
Bishop e6 and the next move by Colin is
just very stylish let's try to find that
one
also it's felis which may makes it even
more appealing
I wouldn't call Eve for fearless
especially there's nothing to fear after
ye for not that it's necessarily a bad
move
however calls and is bit better okay
much better
so the main issue why this facing is the
wrath of these bishops once
efore happens both of those guys and
snipers are going to just fire down the
board so calls then had to be ready for
that to happen
Cement b3 saying actually I'm not scared
of e4 because whenever you play e4 you
give away this fantastic square for my
knight which is protected by that
charger upon which electrifies n charges
this night and this bishop actually can
really pass through that you've got to
exchange it and if you exchange upon
them that's actually favoring the side
which has an extra pawn so b3 it is true
b3 not only stops any threats on the a
and B pawns it also takes away jumps and
important squares from this night and
bishop on e6 so be these main point was
to just take away squares and restrict
these bishops Brooksie to activating the
rook putting pressure on this bishop and
the pawn bishop f1 cold-blooded not
panicking not at all saying okay you've
got one guy attacking that a2 pond not a
problem I have that under control if you
play e4 it's even better because I'm
also attacking the rook and Knight and
the bishop that the knight then it just
gives a very good position for white
extra pawn no clear compensation even
though this rook is still active it's
not enough for a pawn so Knight d5 was
played
and here comes Magnus with the best way
of converting so when you have an extra
pawn what are you supposed to do what
are you guys as fonts what you should be
aiming for when you have that extra pawn
so check mentions 96 ideas but whenever
you already have sort of a winning
adventure at least those are winning
advantages when you have an extra pawn
in the GM level so you don't just want
to suppress your opponent's counterplay
you really want to simplify exactly this
boy I guess points it out want to
exchange pieces because at the end of
the day we will have an extra pawn and
then we'll just be prevailing due to
that Bishop c4 obviously calculated to
the tee putting pressure and would be
extremely happy to exchange of one of
those bishops because at the moment only
shook has the bishop pair and the hope
to use it as a compensation Knight c3
let's try to guess the next move this
one's important because whenever you're
making exchanges you've got to be sure
you're doing it in the right way
and vogue d2 was played here and you
might think the easiest part is to win a
winning position not at all
that's the hardest part Brooke c1 is
actually super dangerous you're inviting
92 trickery it doesn't really work yet
because Bishop takes c4 we have this
in-between move of rook takes c3 however
we do leave the a to pawn on three and
that's not a great thing so not wanting
to lose a winning position played rook
d2 and eliminating that rook avoiding
tricks like this Knight e to fork and
also keeping this exchange operation
alive rook takes D to nine takes D to e
four very good move by owners shook he's
trying to activate this bishop also he
is hinting at this tricky little idea of
90 to check here takes and normally
you'd get two pieces for the rook but in
this specific case there's F take c6 and
you're suffering
actually it's black who's better now so
seeing these tactics coming from a mile
away
he plays King F 1 not only sidestepping
that trick of 92 also bringing in the
King so it had it does serve a dual
purpose rook b8 like c5 so every move by
cousin has a purpose not only does he
removed this Knight from that attack he
also puts pressure on the e6 bishop and
that e4 pawn bishop takes c4 Knight
takes e4
and what is magical and this is high
level chess you'd anticipate some
tactics to work here but it just does
not because calls and calculated it and
knew that okay that is just on the
surface it looks dangerous however it is
not as bad as it looks
rugby 596 another tricky little move and
funnily enough this rook just is running
out of space you can't attack this rook
because my knight is controlling those
squares and you can really go to the C
file because the ape Knight is holding
and controlling those important before
c5 squares and that is surprising
because that not only a six just doesn't
look that good it usually is kind of
awful on the side of the board but in
this specific case it actually works and
it's kind of powerful bishop f8 and the
next move is just brilliant by Carlsen
so pause the video or if you're here
just watching take a look try to solve
this one because Magnus is next move is
out of this world it's very pretty
a move probably completely overlooked by
one issue
so I mentioned before this rook on b5 is
on shaky grounds if you can't use that
fact you might be able to mobilize the a
and B pawns which is the key for victory
in this type of position go wait for it
do take that pawn it's a very vile idea
however it's a little bit flawed b4
exactly and the point is if you just let
me roll that a 4 B 5 you are lost
because there's no way you're gonna ever
stop those pawns from rushing down the
board so unless you have to take now at
the moment everything's safe why doesn't
have a control of the B file so you
can't use this idea also the knight is
defending that rook however there's a
for just kicking this rook out from this
comfortable position and once this rook
moves it's no longer defendant will be 7
Brooke c1 the idea being that there's
this threat of night things b4 if you
take on a4 there is rugby 1 and you lose
the game because the bishop can't move
the rook is hanging and the bishop has
no more defenders so once this Knight
was forced to move as if you don't move
it there's Knight takes b4 rook takes b4
and rook takes c3 and you're just a
piece down you get in to this problem of
not being able to do anything because
once this removed all of the other
pieces got unstable 95 and back and this
time the main issue is you don't have
this counter trick of rook c7 because
yes after
before you can take this night however
mr. Luke see four days and I think is
the five in your loss losing to play
that five instead a five and even though
wide gave back that one pawn owners
shook just lend it up in an eternal pin
you can't do anything about it
King g7 and here comes the decisive
maneuver
let's try to find that because that is
the clincher the icing on the cake
to remember blacks main issue is this
pen so we might want to milk that idea
you never really want to move this night
because it is actually pinning this rook
to b7 - can't really move if we can put
extra pressure on b4 this will be a
gorgeous position for white
therefore Carlsen figured how about I
get my Knight to c6 have a double attack
on b4 and three against two is usually a
winner in a chess game so therefore he
played Knight e5 now only shook still
tried to muddy waters but EF III takes
takes King g1 he had no choice but to go
and ID five and as I mentioned before it
is never too late to mess up a beautiful
game knight c6 would run into Bishop c5
check and you would lose the rook and
probably even the game however Carlson
is vigilant plays King h1
no more Bishop c5 trickery and who's
gonna stop knight c6 I'd be for only
shook tried won't be 5 laughter knight
c6 he gave up as there is no way of
stopping wide from taking the b4 bishop
so I really hope you guys enjoyed this -
splendid Magnus Carlsen and games which
he showed that it constant pressure
eventually you can then very balanced
and games I hope you had a fun time take
care
[Music]
[Applause]
you